there's nowhere in the world I'd rather
be than with my fast family here in the
middle of Rome
I couldn't ask for anything more it's a
dream come true
all right here we go
the heart and soul of The Fast and
Furious franchise boots on the ground on
location
no better place to do it than in Rome
huh I got this no we got this
that was awesome Rome brought scale and
history to the franchise you know we
needed a optical course of source
through one of the most famous cities in
the world it was the playground that the
Fast and Furious franchise was needing
and we're happy that we didn't break
Rome
it's a dream come true you know we'll
work in Rome and then to be on
motorcycles and ride the streets of Rome
is definitely bucket list
on a motorcycle in Rome I mean come on
thank you
everybody loves fast so much that they
want to be part of it Rome was so
welcoming we were authorized to do stuff
that had never been done before I'm
really happy that we got to come to Rome
because Italy has a very special place
in the Fast and Furious heart you know
[Music]
um